MALE SPEAKER: --Jelly Bean.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wan to
learn how to develop fast,
beautiful, engaging
Android apps?
Want to learn on your own
time at your own pace?
We have a suite
of online courses
just for you, developed
by Google experts.
MALE SPEAKER: Confusing
or disorienting.
Just as we learned
how a client--
FEMALE SPEAKER: We have
courses for everybody,
from beginner
programmers to those
of you know your
way around Java who
want to delve into
the depth of Gradle,
learn the fundamentals of
developing Android apps,
build apps that look
cool on all device sizes,
and learn the elements
of great design.
Learn how to extend your apps
to wearable, TV, and auto,
integrate your app
with Google services
like Analytics, Maps,
and Ads, and make
your app fast and efficient.
Start now at udacity.com/google.